[Music]
anticipation was high as the duke and
duchess of cambridge arrived at the
appropriately named king's house
1953 was when the queen first came here
when jamaica was still a british colony
now all eyes on her grandson under
pressure to apologize for the painful
past
i strongly agree with my father the
prince of wales
who said in barbados last year
that the appalling atrocity of slavery
forever stains our history
i want to express my profound sorrow
slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened
while the pain runs deep
jamaica continues to forge its future
with determination
courage and fortitude
father shawn was one of those who wrote
an open letter asking william to
acknowledge the royal family's role in
the slave trade he was left disappointed
it is always disappointing
when
responsibility is not taken
for certain actions and certainly this
is not just any action it's crimes
against humanity
earlier in the day in a surprisingly
blunt meeting in front of the cameras
prime minister andrew holness had
already alluded to the protests
we are moving on
and we intend to
attain
in short order development groups
and focus of our true ambitions
as an independent
developed prosperous
culture his ambitions also clear that
jamaica should cut ties with the royal
family
the royals don't think the republic
debate is one for them but there is no
way that prince william could ignore the
issue of slavery it was always unlikely
that he was going to go further than his
father even though there will be those
disappointed he didn't mention
reparations but in a sign of how much
his words did matter to him he was keen
there were no leaks and they were heard
from him first
william and kate have been left in no
doubt they are forming a new kind of
relationship with jamaica this tour was
never going to solve all of the issues
at play but it has amplified the voices
of those demanding change rhiannon mills
sky news in kingston jamaica